γρήγορα έπρεπε να αλλάξουμε και στο βαθμό που έπρεπε να αλλάξουμε το διόχι τές δεγανι
όταν επεία στη σία η ήτα ήταν ήδη αλλαγμένι λόγο του ανταγωνισμό αλλά δεν ήταν
ο βαθμός της αλλαγισουν εκείνος που θα πρεπε να είναι ήταν ένας βαθμός λλαγής για
επιβίωση αλλά όχι αλλαγή για να είσε για της ήτα θεμα χρόνο δεν αλλάζαμε και
άλλον να μην είμαστε για της σε στιλεπικινωνίες στην κύπρο και νομίζω ότι αυτό που
πετύχαμε τα τελευταία πέντε χρόνια είναι να παραμείνουμε να διαφισβήτητα όηγατης των τηλεπικινειωνιών και να
είμαστε ένας λόγος για τον οποίον η κύπρος να είναι περήφανη και να νιώθουν και
κάποιοι δικαιωμένοι γιατί δεν ίδιοδικοποιήθηκε ενησίτα τότε που ίσως θα θαρωτστοποηθεί πόσον κάκο θεωρτα και
ναο κλώωι θα έκανε ηδιοτικοποίηση ενός οργανισμού σάντησητα σήμερα αθεωρητική συζήτηση σίγουρα και ι διοδιγοποίηση
δεν σημαίνει ότι ησίήτα τον ιδιοτικο αν ήταν η διοτική εταιρία θα από τη εχαν
μπορεί πολύ επιτυχημένοι όπως είναι και τον νομίζω όμως ότι η αξία τη σήτασαν ημικρατικός
οργανισμός αλλά επιτυχημένος που να η γείτε σε έναν μια αγοράν όπου είναι οι διοτικές
εταιρίες που ανταγωνίζετα υτοί αξιά για το κράτος είναι τεράστεια διότι ησι ήταν μπορεί να
είναι παράδειγμα πλέων για έναν επιτυχημένων η μικρατικώ οργανισμό κάτι που δεν υπήρχε περ θέλω
να σας θημίσω ότι πρινν από δέκα χρόνια αυτό η συζητήσεις ήταν ότι αλδεν ίδιοτιοκοποιηθεί
ένας οργανισμός δεν έχει με λπίδα σωτηρίας νομίζω ότι ησίτα απέδειξε ότι μπορεί να πετύχει
ένας ημικρατικός οργανισμός αλλά ι ιστορία φυς γιαά δεν τελειώνεια καδιότι αναγ